we are here in Sarasota County in the
town of Northport and it was a little
bit of an adventure getting in here this
morning Not only was there plenty of
water still on the road there's a lot of
downed trees even on the interstate so
you're having to zigzag around uh trying
to get in the light is starting to come
up here so residents are starting to
walk around and assess some of the
damage plenty of downed trees and of
course this area is without power at
this point right now which also means a
lot of cell phone towers are down any
good news that we can report on this is
that right behind us when we were trying
to strike in we did see some of the
power Crews some of the the front line
of the power Crews coming into the area
so we know that they've been poised
around the state you know roughly 40 000
power Crews ready to get to work and
they are up early and they are up ready
to work right now we're trying to assess
some of the damage and now the lights
coming up we'll have reports later on